whether you're filling out a paper
ballot or you're voting directly onto a
machine there's a computer involved and
all computers have some kind of security
vulnerability attached to them that's
the nature of computers and software so
the question really should be what can
we do to mitigate that risk Super
Tuesday is coming up but as caucuses and
primaries try out new ways to streamline
the voting process questions are being
raised about voting security and to
learn more about voting technology we're
talking to Larry Norden from NYU's
Brennan Center there is no such thing as
a perfect election so there will
certainly be hiccups so in 2020 can we
all be expecting to vote on our phones
I don't think and frankly I hope that
we're not doing that too soon we're not
ready to vote by phone and it's not just
the challenges of being able to transmit
votes in a way that is secure when we
know that there are nation states that
are attempting to interfere in our
elections it's also ensuring that voters
themselves aren't victims of spoofs I
think people often also ask the question
will I I Bank by phone why can't I do
this by phone and there's the additional
challenge of the secret ballot and we
want to ensure that people can vote
privately and the the only way to do
that is to make sure that the system is
extra secure right with my bank they
know how much money I have in my account
and you can go check it you can go to
them and report to that and they should
see it also and when you vote on a
machine there's hopefully a paper record
that they can go to and check to make
sure that the software is recording your
votes accurately and what about people
who've heard things about the Iowa
caucus app in the news a lot of things
went awry what happened in Iowa is a
great example of the challenges of
voting by phone that was an app to
report results it had a lot of issues it
had a lot of issues it didn't work they
were lucky that they had paper backups
that they could go to to add up the
votes and that they can still go back to
- to double-check the results and fix
whatever the problems are if if people
were voting on that app we wouldn't be
able to go back and know with confidence
that the results were accurate and I
think there are a lot of important
lessons from Iowa one of them is that
you don't want to roll out new untested
technology just before a really big
election Macy's wouldn't roll out new
cash registers on Black Friday
Iowa wasn't a primary it was a caucus
which means that the the Democratic
Party was running that it wasn't run by
election professionals I'd like to think
that most election officials wouldn't
make the kind of mistake that they made
in Iowa and it's also a lesson in having
contingency plans having resiliency
plans if something goes wrong what can
you turn to to make sure that the
election still runs smoothly what are
some you know cutting edge technologies
that have really helped to voting and
Election Day is run more smoothly
electronic poll books have been very
helpful in in making the process of
checking into voting faster and
essentially talk to each other so that
if you've checked in on one line
all of the other poll books will know
that you've checked in almost every
state at this point has online voter
registration and that has a lot of
benefits not just because it's easier to
register but because it's also easy to
check if there are any problems with
your registration ahead of time there's
been a move towards paper machines that
relied only on software that didn't have
some kind of paper ballot or paper
backup could be susceptible to hacks and
we would never know it and so there's
been a dramatic move back to paper paper
is a pretty impressive technology it's
it's a very useful technology and it's
very useful redundancy and for something
like voting where there's a secret
ballot where there's not really any
other independent way to check that the
tallies that you're getting from a
software are accurate that you need that
independent record a lot of issues or
problems or bumps in the road are
expected in elections right and election
officials are prepared for that trained
for that and know how to react right
election officials in general have
gotten very good at contingency planning
and thinking about what might go wrong
one of the challenges that we have in an
age of social media and disinformation
is to ensure that every little hiccup
doesn't lead to conspiracy theories or
the assumptions about why they're
happening so if people have heard that
security researchers and security
experts have found flaws and problems
with voting machines what would you tell
them about what's going on with that for
the most part all Americans are voting
on computers whether your fill
a paper ballot or you're voting directly
onto a machine there's a computer
involved and all computers have some
kind of security vulnerability attached
to them that's the nature of computers
and software so the fact that people are
able to find security vulnerabilities in
them isn't that surprising the question
really should be what can we do to
mitigate that risk what can we do to
make sure that if there is some hack or
malware on the system that we catch it
and that we can recover from it and the
big answer for that frankly is having a
paper backup the good news on that is
that's not hard to do and there's no
reason why we shouldn't be able to do it
before the 2020 election we have the
tools to audit if we want to so
currently in the u.s. for this really
diverse system we have what type of
oversight is there for the types of
organizations and companies that are you
know selling equipment and the equipment
itself I make a distinction between the
equipment and the vendors who are
selling the equipment for the equipment
there's some oversight there is a
federal certification process that's
voluntary for voting machines and those
have to be if you want to have a
federally certified machine not
everybody does in the United States but
most states use the program in some way
you have to go through a testing process
that tests around security and usability
and accessibility separate from that is
the companies who work in our elections
the private companies who work in our
elections those private vendors touch
every aspect of our elections and there
there is zero regulation at the federal
level and what that means is you can
have things like happened in Maryland
recently where they discover that one of
their vendors for their registration
system was actually owned by a Russian
oligarch with close ties to Vladimir
Putin they would not have known that if
the FBI hadn't informed that and in fact
that had been the case for a while
before they found out about it so from
my perspective that's a real problem and
we're eventually going to need federal
oversight and involvement in so a lot of
primaries are going to be happening on
Super Tuesday a lot is going to be going
on what can we expect I'm very hopeful
that what we can expect is an election
that goes smoothly
there will be states where voters are
voting on new equipment for the first
time so that made
some challenges to voters who aren't
familiar with the equipment another
thing that we should be expecting is
high turnout and that's something that
we have to be ready for and again I'm
hopeful that election officials are
preparing for that high turnout and that
are ready that if systems fail on that
they have backup plans in place so that
people can still vote and that they can
vote with confidence that their ballots
are going to be counted looking ahead
what trajectory do you think we're on in
terms of the safety security and
stability of elections in the United
States I think the trend is a good one
we haven't done as much as I would have
liked since 2016 but there's no question
that there is a much greater awareness
of election security issues than there
was both in the elections community
among election officials and at the
state and federal level then there was
just a few years ago there's been more
resources devoted to election security
and we've had a move to paper and to
redundancies every battleground state in
the United States now has a paper record
of every vote we are using that paper
more and more to double-check the
accuracy of electronic totals and so
while we're far from where we need to be
and cybersecurity is a race without a
finish line so we're gonna have to keep
investing in it we're we're on the right
course in that we understand that it's a
race and that we're gonna need to
continue to be vigilant and that's
really the most important step that we
could be making yeah there's a lot to
talk through here so thank you so much
for coming thanks slowly